en este vídeo voy a hablar acerca de los
monopolios de los monopolios y por otro
lado también voy a hablar acerca de la
competencia perfecta competencia
perfecta y desde un punto de vista estos
son completamente opuestos pues por un
lado el monopolio tienes exactamente un
jugador y por acá tendrás muchos
jugadores y en el monopolio se obtiene
el conjunto de precios cuantitativo y
para la competencia perfecta tiene que
haber un precio aceptante y si tú
quisieras entrar en un monopolio a
grandes barreras puesto que solo
hablamos de uno pero para entrar en la
competencia perfecta no debe de haberlas
y en este vídeo voy a considerar otro
tipo de situaciones en las que se
encuentren estos y profundizando un poco
más me gustaría agregar o dibujar dos
aspectos que probablemente si los
analizamos y les agregamos variables
donde nadie quiere estar en estos
términos y que en realidad son grandes
términos entonces aquí lo voy a dibujar
de una sola dimensión y no pensaré en el
número de competidores sólo lo anotar y
entonces ahora sabemos que en un
monopolio solamente es un competidor y
una competencia perfecta tenemos varios
competidores o los suficientes
tenemos un voucher por aquí y solamente
uno por acá en este punto de aquí
tendríamos cero donde no hay
competidores o no hay mercado y en el
eje vertical que estoy dibujando cómo
puedo pensar en cómo hacer una
diferencia entre competidores que hay en
el mercado cómo son los diferentes
productos o marcas que hacen la
diferencia entre estos entonces aquí le
pondré la diferenciación entre estos y
por acá pondremos baja o alto
dependiendo de cómo vaya a ser y
entonces vamos a pensar en las
diferentes industrias pensemos acerca de
dónde están situadas y después voy a
introducirte a nuevas palabras otras
palabras que no sólo sean monopolio o
competencia perfecta ahora imaginemos
que vivimos en un mundo donde hay 50
productores de tornillos y que todos
estos tornillos son un grupo
completamente idéntico y con esto algún
productor si comienza a tener más o
mejores producciones sabrás que querrás
comprar con él porque ellos pueden tener
exactamente las mismas cosas que
nosotros pero con un mejor precio por lo
que esto sería un caso de baja
diferenciación puesto que todos los
grupos de tornillos son los mismos y por
eso forman parte
una baja diferencia así que esto es
acerca de la competencia perfecta que se
puede dar en la vida real aunque en
realidad no estoy segura si los
manufactureros de tornillos tengan un
buen equipo de competidores y un buen
equipo de publicistas y si ellos
enredado tienen entonces estás
completamente cerca de lo que es la
competencia perfecta y en otro aspecto
imagina que tus utilidades o impuestos
la mayoría de las veces en algunos
lugares especialmente en los eeuu pero
probablemente en todo el mundo solamente
hay una entidad que los controle y vayan
dirigidos a líneas de energía o algún
otro tipo de subsidio y esta entidad
siempre es el gobierno solamente el
gobierno lo regula o alguna empresa
privada pero solamente uno por lo que en
este caso tendría solamente un jugador
que será el gobierno y aquí no habría
debate con alta o baja diferencia pues
solamente es el único jugador entonces a
esto que le llame utilidad lo voy a
etiquetar por aquí abajo en la baja
diferenciación pues solamente es uno y
si te das cuenta es algo cercano a un
monopolio de hecho es como un monopolio
porque es el único jugador que hay y
monopolio significa mono viene de uno y
paul y viene de competidor entonces se
refiere a uno
y entre otras cosas también tengo un
ejemplo que pensé acerca de los
teléfonos celulares pues como tú sabes
en nuestras áreas normalmente hay varias
telefonías que nos ofrecen o nos
proporcionan el mismo servicio pues más
ahora con la era del internet muchas
compañías telefónicas nos ofrecen este
servicio más a un cable o las de cable
también nos quieren ofrecer el servicio
telefónico e internet y viceversa lo que
está creando que este sector crezca
demasiado por lo que analizar este
sector nos puede aportar demasiado y
como son varios competidores pero no
tanto es la diferenciación nos pondremos
por aquí está el cable internet y
también las líneas telefónicas
ahora bien podemos pensar en otro
ejemplo de un mercado donde haya
realmente demasiados competidores pero
entre ellos si hayan diferencias con su
mercancía puedo pensar en algo como no
sé buena comida puesto que hay varios
restaurantes en donde estos negocios
realmente se definen por su calidad de
comida y la gente que los produce tienen
la mejor limpieza por lo que ellos
tienden a dar una alta diferenciación
pues estos restaurante
son únicos y con grandiosos chefs que
especialmente tienen en el restaurante
pero aquí estoy hablando de demasiados
estos serían demasiados restaurantes por
lo que los voy a escribir por aquí buena
restaurantes de buena comida luego por
otro lado también podríamos imaginar o
pensar acerca de marcas que definen la
ropa que se diferencian entre sus
diseñadores o por los materiales que
están hechos otro ese tipo de cosas que
también forman varios tipos de
competencias entre ellos entonces aquí
pondré los nombres o las marcas de de
diferentes tipos de ropa pero su
clasificación no forman los suficientes
como para decir que se crea una
competencia perfecta pero lo que sí es
que si son varios jugadores solo que
ellos no venden el tipo de producto
ellos sí son muy diferenciables y si
atrás un poco hacia tu vida real tú
estarás de acuerdo conmigo a que si te
acercas un punto a este tipo de mercados
se podrá decir que ellos tienen un
monopolio con sus productos también por
otro lado si pensamos un poco acerca de
las computadoras o laptops podremos
llamar a un grupo a un cierto grupo de
los de alta gama y bueno yo en sí quiero
en general de todo tipo de computadoras
o lo que me refiero en este caso a las
computadoras apple puesto que la mayoría
de la gente prefiere comprar estas y
bueno también hay cierta gente que
también prefiere comprar sony o no sé
quizás otro tipo de marcas así que tal
vez pondremos otras marcas de
competencia que aparecerán por otro lado
pues puede ser que tú tengas o que has
comprado cualquier tipo ps del mercado
pues puede que tengan las mismas tipos
de funciones y tú simplemente te
interese utilizar estas y que no vayas
en realidad solamente porque son lindas
o porque te interesa la marca así que
éstas tienen menos diferencia y las
acomodaremos por aquí sin marca y esta
tendencia pasaría con computadoras
personales de la industria y como puedes
observar éstas tienden a estar cerca de
los tornillos y su perfecta competencia
entonces al final todo este conjunto de
ideas que introduje es para usarlas con
cierto objetivo puesto que son varios
nombres varios nombres de cosas que no
son de competencia perfecta pero sí
tienen grandes diferencias entre ellos y
los nombres de este conjunto que tenemos
por aquí que al final son bastantes como
para formar un monopolio porque ellos
son algunos proveedores del mismo
de mercancía en estos que acabo de
encerrar en el círculo podríamos poner
otras cosas alrededor de estos mismos
que en general los llamaremos
oligopolios si los llamaremos
oligopolios donde all y esta esta parte
de aquí viene del griego aunque no soy
experta en esto del griego pero viene de
pocos y obviamente paul y viene una vez
más como la de monopolios que se refiere
a competidores por lo que justo
significa con pocos o algunos
competidores y los oligopolios
finalmente los podemos ordenar por
estatus y con muchísimos más detalles
ellos no son bastantes como para ser
monopolios ellos no pueden establecer un
precio no cuantitativo ellos simplemente
tienen una especie de tipo de oligopolio
que depende del mercado ellos pueden
empezar actuando más como un monopolio
si los jugadores se pusieran a coordinar
unos con otros se obtuvieron un
beneficio múltiple o ellos por este lado
deberán de convertirse en feroces
competidores inclusive si son pocos
patrocinadores pueden formar una especie
de personalidad con características
donde ellos puedan inclusive ser como un
tipo de monopolio pero en realidad serán
como una especie de compañías muy
competitivas y esto
cosas aparecen donde hay bastante
competencia entre industrias estas son
bastante competitivas tal que crean
grandes diferencias entre ellos que en
algún grado se puede decir que como un
ejemplo sería con las computadoras de
app porque forman a la vez un monopolio
pues solamente venden sus productos en
sus tiendas apple por lo que si te das
cuenta esta marca tiene una tendencia
evidentemente egoísta por lo que tiende
a diferenciarse de las demás y ser un
tipo de monopolio con su producto pero
hasta cierto punto afortunadamente hay
muchos pero realmente muchos
competidores quienes forjan a paul a
mantener un cierto precio puesto que
ellos ofrecen productos que son
finalmente casi lo mismo porque es la
misma propuesta pero son diferentes de
alguna manera así que a estos jugadores
que están aquí los podremos llamar
mercados de competencia monopólica y
cuando escuches esto por primera vez
suena un poco extraño porque solo
estamos acostumbrados a que lo primero
para nosotros son los monopolios pero
esto es más por lo menos en mi mente
algo como como competencia perfecta
un pequeño monopolio porque es algo que
yo creé solitariamente monopolios
completamente incompetentes y bueno esto
se interpreta como alta competencia no
son bastantes sino más bien me refiero a
su alta diferenciación por lo que los
crea como dice como competencia perfecta
pero está cercano a tener un monopolio
solamente que en un producto tuyo lo que
pasa es que entre más alternativas hay
en el mercado afecta a la demanda de la
gente hacia un producto y el mejor
regalo entre competidores monopólicos y
competencia perfecta es que algunos haga
la diferencia entre los años de y la
calidad de los productos que cada uno le
brinde a éstos